This is an increasingly common sight in Kenya.
Graveyards of what once were mighty forests, teeming with life.
The Kakamega Forest in Western Kenya is one of the country's last remaining stands.
Plants in the forest are being damaged or killed because people harvest them for traditional medicines.
So, to save Kakamega Forest,...
...an international research group has transferred two popular plants out of the forest...
...and into the hands of farmers such as Mary Shimuli.
Shimuli grows a half-acre's worth of Ocimum kilimandscharicum...
...and harvests the plant every six months.
She says that, besides saving the forest,...
...her harvests bring her family a better income.
I used to go to the forest for firewood but I was afraid of being arrested.
After I realized that the project is fruitful for me,...
...I stopped going to the forest.
I managed to buy two cows.
Shimuli and other farmers bring what they harvest to a nearby factory owned and operated by the community...
...and supported by African Insect Science for Food and Health or ICIPE.
The ocimum is weighed, dried, then processed.
The oil extracted is used to manufacture Naturub,...
...a balm and an ointment used to treat flu,...
...cold, chest congestion, aches, pain and insect bites.
The products have been certified and approved by the government.